[Music]  girl power was a big theme at the 2018  Billboard Music Awards as Christina  Aguilera and Demi Lovato delivered a  powerful performance and Taylor Swift  praised pioneering women in music I want  to thank all the artists all the female  artists who paved the way for us xtina  and Demi teamed up to sing their duet  fall in line a passionate anthem about  liberation surrounded by dancers in  military garb the powerhouse singers  belted the poignant lyrics equally  inspiring Taylor Swift speech for best  female artist I'm on an all female  artist stadium tour right now so I have  to start out by saying thank you to my  tour mates Charli XCX and Camilla Kibeho  the singer also took a moment to  acknowledge female artists who are just  starting out all the new artists the new  female artists who are killing it out  there right now we're so inspired by you  and and I don't know a shout out to the  the Future female artists who just  picked up a guitar or learned how to  play piano